να σχοληθεί τώρα που προχωρά προς το τελο σηθητία αρχικά πως νιώθεται που σεμερικές εβδομάδες
ολοκριώνεται μια διαδρομή πέντε των σαν επίτροπος δεν ξέρον το έχω συντοποιησι απόλητα πρέπει ν
από την αλήθεια ήταν ήταν επιλογή μου ολοκληρώνοντας στη θυτία μου να επιστρέψω στην κύπρο
πιστεποότι αυτό που σε κάνει να νιώθεις καλά η όχι καλά όταν φεύπεις από ποιαδήποτε
θέση είναι ανεσθάνεσαι ότι έχεις δώσει τον καλύτερο σοε αυτό χωρίς να ξημαίνει ότι έχει
πετύχει ι όλι βθεωρούν ότι ήταν μια πετυχημένη θυτία αλλά εκείνο πουν μπορών από για
τον έ αυτό μου τουλαχιστο ενα ότι φεύγοντας σθάνουμε ότι έδωσα ότι μπορούσα το καλύτερο
για για τον τόπο μου και για το χαρτοφυλάκιο μου για για την εγεία των
ευροπαίων πολιτών αναλάβατε σαν επίτροπο και μετά πο λύγες εβδομάδες ξεσπά επανδημία του κορονοιου τι
θυμαστε από κίνη την περιομα ήταν ένας τέσθερεις ευδομάδες μετά για για πολούς που δεν
ξέρουν τα πρώταπεριστατικά που είχαμε κορονοϊού η αρχαν αρχίσει το φευράρι στην ηταλλεία αλλά εγώ
από τις αρχές του γενάρι είχα έτσι μια ε ενημέρωση από τον παγκόσμε οργανισμό ηγίας
αλλά και μια διαίσθυση αν θέλετε ότι κάτι εξελίσετου που ήταν πιθανότατα διαφορετικό και έτσι
από τιος αρχές του γερνάριχα δημειουργή σει μια ομάδα στην στη δική μου στη δική
μομάδα που να σχολούμεστε με το κόβιτ θυμάμε πάρα πολύ δύσκολες καθημερινές καθμια δύσκολικά θημερινότητα
μια εα